wanted to relive one of the great
episodes of shark tank where the guy
is pitching something that supposedly is
going to get rid of bad habits
by tasing you basically so i bought his
product
every time i fake laugh i'm going to
give myself a little zap guys today
we're watching
one of the all-time great episodes of
shark tank and if you haven't
uh watched this yet we're gonna relive
it together with a twist
listen i'm now a daily uploader uh which
i have no respect for no respect for
daily uploaders
but now that i am one myself one bad
habit i want to get rid of
is fake laughing fake laughing is it
see i just did it i just you hear that
little chuckle
no no no no no no no no no last time
every other youtuber does that i'm like
come on dude and then i catch myself
listen it's in the dna of
daily uploaders you're just like in
there and you're like gotta get a piece
of content out
get that fake laugh going baby anyway so
i'm trying to break myself up that habit
just so happens i also wanted to relive
one of the great episodes of shark tank
where the guy is pitching something that
supposedly is gonna get rid of bad
habits
so i bought his product and we're gonna
be reacting to
his video where he goes down in shark
tank fail history you're in
get them out of here while also getting
my rid of my bad ab
ah i did it again see now i'm gonna show
you how this works
every time i fake laugh i'm gonna give
myself a little zap
let's see how the first one feels i hate
doing this this
is really hard to do like shock yourself
this is number one problem with the
product
you have to get rid of your bad habit
you shock yourself every time you do the
bad activity so
let's do it okay problem one with the
product
half the time the shocks don't go
through maybe that's part of the product
just like adds the edge if you don't
know so
it'll you'll see the well
if it lights up oh there it goes it
lights up
no no zap other times it feels like a
scorpion just stung me in the arm
so i'll try to be honest with when i get
shocked when i don't get shocked but
that's how this game is played
let's get started from the beginning by
the way just gotta be honest with you
adrenaline runs through you every time
you press this thing because you're like
am i going to get tased
with the force of a military great taser
or
am i going to feel nothing it's a scary
thing honestly
deadly i'd rather just shock me because
i just track what you do
but actually changes what you do padlock
helps you become aware
by alerting you when you do behaviors
you'd like to reduce then simply press
the button
and pavlock releases a mild electric
nothing my old maybe it's because i have
2.0
there's nothing wrong about it sensation
that helps you reduce cravings
you can laugh but it's actually
something very serious i am laughing it
releases a mild electric sensation that
helps you reduce cravings and actually
breaks bad habits in the brain
how did you come up with this idea i've
always had severe add
i could never get myself to actually get
stuff done i couldn't get myself to
commit to anything
so i did what any normal person would do
i hired someone to sit down next to me
and slap me in the face
what every time i went on facebook and i
wrote a blog
no barbara not nice creepy weird
oh no
and there goes problem number one let's
go let's try it out
okay hey listen it's not my fault if it
doesn't work it's not my fault if it
doesn't zap me okay his fault for
shipping a bad product
see that's something they don't know in
this shark tank episode is like the
product
half works do they actually slap this
video from me getting slapped did you
get the work done
i did yeah it was really cool yeah what
made you come up with this idea yeah i
was visiting a friend
i'm like dude why are we why am i paying
i could just make a make a zapper that
zaps every time i go on facebook
[Music]
after one moment um i just want to
explain kind of the science behind it
and then i'll bring it out for you
now you're already noticing that he kind
of is a little aggressive with like i'll
run this presentation thank you very
much
that's going to continue and these
facial expressions
will continue to get worse it's a slight
electric stimulus that's done while
doing a
undesired bad habit i bite my nails i'm
trying to not bite my nose all the time
where it falls down for me is if i have
the discipline
to buzz myself do i not have the
discipline to stop
people okay people anytime you hear the
stuttering like okay well um you need to
relax if you're up on that shark tank
stage otherwise
it's like smelling blood i mean they
start small blood in the water it's
honestly what it is
cool you have the discipline to stop
well i don't do you wish you could stop
i do so can i so here's your premises
nonsense robert it's all nice across the
board
just i'm i can't get around that like
i'm just i want to bite my nails
and for me to stop i have to hit this
thing correct
and you don't want to hit it trust me i
honestly full disclosure i've had this
thing
for like a week and a half and i didn't
want to use it because i was like dude
this thing
it's like a jack-in-the-box where you
like crank it like you don't know when
it's gonna shock you when it's not
isn't this just like a rubber band on
your wrist that you snap
but just a hundred and fifty dollars
sure why can't laurie
buzz it for me she can i'm she
absolutely can there's a remote control
there's a uh there's a remote control
app there's automation that sounds
correct percentage of time does it not
work
uh it doesn't work if you don't want it
to work
no actually it doesn't work a lot of the
time so you watch
didn't feel it again dude
i've done it like four times already it
hasn't worked a single time i'm honestly
disappointed so it does oh
wow yeah of course so if you use it on
sugar after about three or four days on
like a cookie or
tortilla chips you'll start to notice
the flavor changes now what's
interesting oh
no no no no the flavor changes yeah
you're such a
con artist con artist
he just comes out and says it and i'll
give myself a zap for that one because
there's a little bit of it
i can't tell honestly i'm so deep in the
daily grind i don't even know what my
real life is like anymore i'm just like
see guys this is why i need this and by
the way it didn't shock me again
dude this is a piece of junk i thought
this was going to be a great challenge
it's
ow okay okay a little bit of a delayed
one on that one
dude that actually legit hurts oh dude
it just okay take a break that doesn't
count
this thing just started like
uncontrollably zapping me sorry i had to
take it off i gotta like
reset the the programming of this thing
for a second what the heck
this thing is the worst design product
of all time
i pressed it like four times it didn't
work and then all of a sudden it's not
supposed to be working and i'm like
getting shocks through my arm
this thing sucks that's what i get for
making fun of this guy
he's probably like somehow getting in
here he may be listening to me it's
probably how these things make money
probably listens to him
and uh he's like oh yeah you want to
talk text me
give you a little zap ow all right
let's try again results mark more than
fifty percent of our users break their
habit and five days in seven days or
less first point
okay let me just leave this step one
minute
what you're going oh i love skepticism
because that guy's an idiot
he doesn't even know what he's talking
about
you want to get a deal explain to me why
you're worth 14 million dollars
that's right 50. what is it how much
he's like not 14
15 million because you can't do math you
idiot look if the product worked if the
product didn't randomly shock you
it like didn't not shock you when it was
supposed to shock you you might actually
have a real product here
the problem is his arrogance combined
with that number one
number one our sales are great what are
your sales and we actually just began
shipping this week
we've sold eight hundred thousand
dollars of revenue wait wait pre-orders
three-fourths of the users were
pre-orders and one-fourth of the users
were prototypes what did each of those
people
pay for one device too much 200 how much
too much
200 but i paid for this
who buys these so our biggest users are
youtubers
let's try again let's roll the dice
okay it didn't work it didn't even turn
on that time
i'm so pissed this is 200
do you guys hear me 200 for uh
all it does it's just like a big battery
it's just supposed to shock you in an
app
and it doesn't work this is such trash
dude
this thing doesn't work sorry sitting
too long waking up on time
nail biting and eating so we've started
to build out multiple really cool
integrations for them
oh yeah everything is the alarm clock
what the heck that works
it's a delay it's a time it's a ticking
time bomb
this thing ah i hate this i hate this is
a dumb idea
because i thought you had a real product
okay i thought you had a real product
what you have is a torture device you
have a stanley milgram experiment
on your wrist we're gonna try this one
more time okay
bud four sharks are out but kevin seems
interested in manisha's habit-breaking
watch
pavlok i believe this technology works
because i've seen it work
your valuation bro that face
unbelievable
it's the way he's making these
expressions is unbelievable he's just
like
instead of having a face that says i'm
here you know i respectfully he's like
so condescending is crazy
okay i'm sorry it's not worth 15.9
million now
i'm gonna solve the problem in deal
structure i'm very creative
i'll give you the 500 000 as debt on the
company okay
you're going to give me the 3.14 percent
as equity today
and you're going to walk out of here
with a shark tank deal i'm going to put
it on for 24 months
at seven and a half percent and balloon
payment be back in two years
kevin o'leary loves these like these
terrible deals
if one third of projections are right
you can easily do that
it's an offer it's an offer this is the
problem um
damn there's something there's no
problem
so the problem is that we're not focused
on the money we're focused
more on the focus on the money
why did you come to shark tank if you're
not focused on
the money you've come to the wrong place
my friend i'm here to make money let it
finish
our big okay that's a real laugh
dude mark human cracks me up he's like
you can see it in his face
he's so excited to just see this guy
implode look at those eyes i honestly
thought manish had the best eyebrows in
the game
no mark cuban dude got some brows this
thing our biggest goal is to break bad
habits around the world and mr wonderful
like i just i
i can't work with you why not i'm just
worried that if you work together
i like him i do like him as a person but
i feel like as an investor in the
company would be really bad
you didn't want an offer here today you
really want an offer right i'll say you
got one and why don't you want the
structure of that offer
the structure's actually quite good uh
what's the person
it's the person i feel like you just
said you like mr wonderful
but now you're gonna say you don't
i would take an offer from anybody
besides mr wonderful
[Applause]
manish you already
yes okay well give this man what he
deserves for torturing me all episode
and yes i'll give myself a final shock
for it okay and then i'm immediately
taking it off if it doesn't work because
this thing is a death trap
okay it didn't work i'm taking this
piece of crap off and never
dude you're a you're a piece of work bud
look at that
you don't even have a good product it's
not even that people don't like you
which they didn't in shark tank okay
because you were rude and condescending
it's also that your product just doesn't
work
sorry if you are you all out yeah we're
all out
yes
ah i just feel so good
i have a tinge of regret for rejecting
the deal with mr wonderful
but the truth is our company is building
something much bigger than
no you're not you're building it for
idiots like me who want content
you're not building it for like real
people wanting to break their habits
because no one wants to deal with that
little trap we're trying to change human
behavior
and kevin wouldn't be the right partner
for us to work with i'm telling you
whether it was you
or me or robert or one of us he was
going to do that to somebody it just
happened to be you were the last guy i
realized he's a gold digger he's an
idiot he's a con artist this technology
he thinks he's sincere
technology kevin don't feel bad i don't
feel bad don't feel bad
dude did you hear that he goes don't
feel bad kevin i don't feel bad and then
he's like
sad kevin look at this it's so sad play
the music
music don't feel bad don't feel bad
[Music]
oh it's okay kevin it's okay you're
patting on that
for kevin uh okay
okay that's me sincerely laughing this
is a good this is good
see i in some ways maybe this helped me
i don't know you'll let me know in the
future videos
do you think it's helped me get rid of
my addiction to fake laughing as a daily
uploader
uh let me know if not whatever i'm never
putting that stupid padlock on again i
had other content ideas with it but i'm
not sure
that i'm willing to risk the um the
random shocks i mean i feel like if you
deserve the shock that's fine i get it i
signed up for that
the random shocks is it's uncomfortable
it really is so let me know what you
think of the comments below
don't go harass anybody listen to the
guy it's just funny we all react and if
anything i'm the one who took the l on
this one
all right well that's it thanks for
watching see you next
wake up and time the coffee